you know there's a boom in visitor
numbers it's actually quite expensive
coming to London and I think domestic
tourism probably is a bit we found out
at the academy we get lots of friends
who come very regularly because they
vary what's a subscription but actually
people are quite / sensitive we're
feeling you know people's payers not
gone up and they're making decisions as
to whether or not they come to London
five times a year for tempting I mean
it's not one thing that strikes me
you're looking at those numbers they
jump around years year surely it just
depends on what kind of exhibitions they
only for example we had that Matisse one
at the take which drew in record numbers
isn't covered by those figures so you
know when you've got a big blockbuster
exhibition you're going to get the
crowds in I blame a decline in numbers
on the fact that there's not enough art
in schools I think there should be more
art on the school curriculum art should
be encouraged you know you don't go to
an art gallery to learn how to become a
scientist or a doctor or pilot or a
mathematician but in order to be
creative and end up in one of those
professions art does help you you know
it's like carbohydrate for the eyes or
vitamins for the soul you know it's
necessary as part of our daily life and
more people don't realize the merits of
going to an art gallery which is a shame
and it does come down to education your
gallery did you roll Academy it puts on
Big Show's and it charges for them we do
the point about the tape the National
Gallery's is that they're free
effectively to go into and and we are
told by the politicians one of the
reasons why their fries because they
want to encourage local people and
everyone to feel that they have access
to the National I think unfortunately
somebody at nash gary said it's because
we're an increasingly events based
culture and actually i was thinking
about it as i was coming here if I go to
New York I will go to miss him so now go
to their family collection so I'll go to
the Frick but in London I myself at the
weekend will go to exhibitions more
often than our
permanent collections and I think days
are shifting balance towards it once
honest exhibitions which a package where
you see something which has a narrative
and people know why they're going even
though they pay they don't necessarily
go to permanent collections in the way
they used to and what's your reaction to
that because it does seem that you know
when you look at these museums the ones
that cover these figures that all the
ones that don't charge so Zen point I
think we need to alert people of the
wonderful collections we do have on our
doorstep that in essence do belong to us
maybe more of the marketing money has to
be spent less on the big blockbuster and
more of what's available every day of
the week I think that is correct because
in these institutions and run one of
them you can justify spending money on a
temporary exhibition because you keep it
in the money you get at the cake whereas
in a national collection and I worked in
national collections you don't advertise
the fact you've got a puro on the
doorstep people will go to Italy in
order to go on the period trail but they
forget that they can go on the peerage a
trail in the National and I think we
don't do nearly enough to communicate
that and yet the counter this is the
British Museum which seems to have no
problems with visitors from either
either category well maybe that's more
to do with again the school curriculum
maybe being more child-friendly because
it's to do with the school curriculum
but you know every time you go into an
art gallery it's like walking onto a
plot of soil and your nourished you know
you grow and it's just just the most
wonderful magical experience and that's
what we need to get across and and it's
there every day of the week not just in
a blockbuster and he doesn't mean that
it's up to galleries to put on more
activities that engage in particular
young a visitor I took all of all of us
are doing that or not I think this issue
of encouragement in people to be aware
of what is on their doorstep I think
that thing that people you know when
they travel they get the guide and they
think what what can I go to in via now
if I go to Madrid I'll go to the Prado
and people forget that the DNA has
unbelievable wealth of things in its
Commission or the wallace collection of
the soul music I mean could it just be
that I don't know spanish or Italians or
French people are just more interested
in painted art than we are in this
country no I think I think a lot of it
also has to do with the fact that we we
want to be interactive with what's
around us you know Google games well
that's it you know so perhaps you know
we need and you know I hear people
saying I won't go and see it because I
can google that work of art but you
don't get the same experience you know
you have a certain dialogue and intimacy
with the work of art it's like falling
in love all over again you know the
world complex is managed to put a
negative spin on watch it's essentially
a very positive story enormous big
numbers of people are going to the
church in Nashville Gary it's just that
there's more more tourists again and
somewhat viewer I mean I don't know what
blows me off going to places like the
Tate Modern is the num the crowds
illness yep and Tate Modern you know
people go as tourists it was it was a
new thing in two thousand and the truth
is that the way people work is they've
been to take modern several times and
they don't necessarily go again
unfortunately i remember those are the
two biggest aren't they and but if you
look at the rest of numbers the others
i've actually seen attendance figures
going up so yeah I mean dando not
suppressing it a national project Gary
when I was there we did the memory test
in an exhibition and the numbers went up
to 1.5 million and I thought Paul
sending down would never be able in it
would be unimaginable to ever to be able
to match that it would only go down I
was completely wrong it's gone up and up
and up and it's now two men in a year
frankly when i was there was I couldn't
imagine two minutes get outside alone
and we're also seeing galleries and
museums failing well the Whitworth in
Manchester's just reopened it to
wonderful rave reviews but we've come to
sort of expect that we need to be
entertained we're a bit lazy going to a
gallery we go to a gallery in it and
expect to find a funfair there sometimes
it is
but you know we need to put in some
effort but there are great rewards okay
thank you